[Music]
foreign
whatever it makes you better
[Music]
no one knows what that means welcome
back to new rock stars this is the break
room our daily show that keeps you
updated on just what's going on in
glizzy news
i am hosting today as i have been this
week usually behind the camera um but
with me
is jessica clemens
[Music]
um
also
that's it also that's it that's me and
jess today
also uh koi jondro yeah i got his name
you got it right right appreciate that
thank you a little change
and next to him
erica
everyone thinks your name is erica
whenever i say you're full
not the worst thing i've ever been
called that's right okay
um
coming up on the show today we've got uh
an old script in the teleprompter what
did i
yeah
okay here we go we've got stranger
things you saw it in the thumbnail um
we've also got some thor love and
thunder deleted characters this made
sort of bigger news today you might have
already seen it um one of us
also
may die that's not facetious it's gonna
be a dangerous show let me explain um
at the bottom of the screen it's not up
yet uh dashiell if you could hit that
toggle uh overlay button you see glee
i hate this so much
lazy goblin time uh it's fourth of july
weekend here in the united states
technically it's fourth of july weekend
everywhere in the world that's how
calendars work um
we're doing a special redemption today
because we're not doing a show tomorrow
with me
i have can we cut to the white shot
please oh wait don't get rid of it i
like it can i just it's just a secret i
just want to show i just want to show
everyone what we're working on
um
an absorbent amount of glizzies um
here's how this is gonna work
they're hot
here's how this is gonna work at the
hundred dollar mark which we're getting
close to already i'm a little scared um
myself coy and eric are gonna be
participating in a hot dog eating
contest
now jessica is officiating we we start
with one whoever eats the first one the
fastest wins that round
if we get to 200
each of us has to eat an additional two
so that's three total
and so on and so forth
uh
someone
six hot dogs i don't know why philip
molina gave me a show
i don't think he anticipated this would
happen no one comes i
i'll also say some of these hot dogs i
haven't told you guys this yet oh some
of these hot dogs are spicy
there's a twist
you may keen i might be able to tell
which is which but
um excited i do like cheese or some sort
of liquid in some of them there is none
we're gonna be sort of revisiting some
of your questions at the end of the show
um so get them in now while you can and
while they force us to eat hot dogs um
one thing we should get are they warm is
a poncho or raincoat for jessica i mean
you better not be smacking
just in case these glitzies look great
the thing is you're wearing a white
shirt a beautiful shirt if i messed up
oh well thank you my actions are better
than first period superman i mean i'm
just uh it's the kind of vibe the
world's in right now it just felt like
it's uh that's right i like your
optimism is what i'm saying
um
uh we want to get into the headlines
though
thank you for playing
um
stranger things chapter four volume two
releases two nights on netflix that's
what we're all talking about in the
office right now um we're gonna come
back to this conversation in a bit but i
wanna get quick like
one-word reactions from you guys about
not one word but you know what are you
most excited about what what do you how
do you feel
uh in brief i thought part one was as
good as season one and season one is
amongst my favorite seasons of
television ever so if this sticks the
landing this could cement stranger
things as one of the great shows of all
time
big words yeah
everybody dying everybody everywhere
everybody dying
and it's gonna be like two movies right
yeah it's gonna be like five hours part
one is an hour and a half and part two
the first episode's an hour and a half
and the second episode is two and a half
hours
my buddies
watching these
all night and all tomorrow but i'm
excited i i've loved every bit of this
season yeah action-packed and intense
and i can't wait to see where they go
with what's your over-under on steve
save it save it okay okay there's
another one there's a part two just like
this
yeah thoughts i think i think steve's
gonna survive
nancy's gonna die i'm tired of saying
and i think noah schnapp who does whose
will uh kind of leaked it on his own
tick-tock
oh no
they got his birthday wrong he's like
burn it down
but um no i'm very excited someone
already asked me in the chat and we
already know my number one my baby my
crush is eddie before you go jessica
eddie's 19 i'm like uh the actor is my
age and that's who i'm attracted to
he is a gorgeous man and i love him in
game of thrones so british ooh so
love it uh we're gonna come back to
stranger things here in a second but
first uh warner brothers moved a little
a few things around in their release
slate uh dune part two is gonna
shift a month from uh i believe it was
coming out october 20th 2023 it's moving
to november 17 2023
it's it's a better day but it's also
competing with that hunger games prequel
that we don't really know much about we
just got like a sort of title sting
for and they also dated i'm very excited
about this godzilla versus kong two
whatever that's gonna be called march 15
2024
it takes a lot to feed those two guys so
you know they're in hibernation
um
this is a horrible show
indiana this came out a couple days ago
but uh we wanted to talk about it
indiana jones 5 might be harrison ford's
last movie when speaking about indiana
jones 5 potentially being his final film
score john williams said hey if it's
ford's last film maybe it'll be mine too
people are sort of anticip interpreting
that two ways right
is this their last film
is this their last indiana film uh i
don't know i feel like they've been
saying this is our last indiana jones
film since indiana jones and the last
crusade this is really the last
halloween though halloween ends and it's
done they're open
five years we get another halloween yeah
i don't i don't trust any of this it's
great
because he's probably so tired he's so
tired he's so tired you know he started
as a carpenter
i've seen his door oh yeah he's like i
want to go back to making doors yeah
and after enough doors fall on him i
mean this poor guy you can only crash
doors and claims
that said harrison ford's whole vibe at
the star wars celebration was
magnificent like he came out and there
was such respect and reverence and like
there was such earnest
appreciation for the whole room and
that's one of the things i've been
saying like star wars celebration got me
back on star wars i was done i was out
like well the internet's so loud and
angry yeah so like it was the keyboard
cowboys made me think that's what star
wars was now and then i went to
celebration and i was like this is
powerful like this is love this is
welcoming and harrison ford like felt
that too and it was really great to see
him in reverence for john williams and i
if this is the last one i think he's
going to go out on top i'm really
excited for you there you go baby i'm
too i am too um let's not remember the
dog movie keep going
or indeed poor crystals
yeah oh no i like that movie
during your interview with i'm not gonna
tell you kevin mccarthy chris hemsworth
revealed this is a question for you guys
actually uh we've got two people on the
panel who have seen thor love and
thunder already chris hemsworth revealed
that alongside his son playing young
thor we saw a shot of that in the
trailer his daughter is also in the film
as a character called love you have love
you have thunder um
is it
a parent who
who um
if you can't say that's fine no you you
his daughter is playing or is it more of
like a blink and you miss it kind of
thing the beautiful thing about love is
that it's whatever you think it is okay
okay and the beautiful thing about love
is that it's what you experience love to
be and the beautiful thing about love
and thunder is that it's playing in
theaters next friday
and now we can talk about it
and speaking of things that i don't want
to do uh right now which i don't want to
do get you in legal trouble um
we just crossed we just crossed the
glizzy hundred dollars
actually thank you so they've crossed
the glizzy line for that moment that was
happening so jessica is going to give us
the countdown coy i believe you wanted
to muster the dog yeah yeah yeah let me
just go ahead and con a minute are you
going ketchup is getting ketchup which
is whoever is watching this you guys
take screenshots of the screen mm-hmm
tweet at
the prequels are a rough time already
i'll also say i had
a big lunch today because i was on
autopilot and wasn't thinking about this
walked in and was like i had two hot
dogs before
all week if i went to five guys
are you guys ready when i say go you
guys are gonna shove those glizzies to
the back of your throat
one
two
three
go
oh john's winning john's oh oh coy's
getting there koi's getting there
there's oh okay okay
so
eric get in there get in there okay okay
eric's coming up on top air's coming up
on top john you're going behind now john
you're going behind oh koi is shoveling
koi said i'm using the shoveling method
shoveling mess oh my god baby bird john
has swallowed his glizzy
he has swallowed the gliss
okay we get it we we work with what we
have in our budget
uh and i i honestly wait we're still
waiting we're still waiting he's still
chomping um you two are not winning but
you're almost there
you don't talk with your mouth full
yo mizzy
oh my god
oh my god the bread sticking to every
surface that's why i told you you had to
dip it in the water first and we have a
winner john
wow okay so the dog the dog wants a
glitz i was unprepared for how the bread
was gonna stick to everything the bread
is really tough
that's why you use the water
i might have to do a dip next time yeah
good lord yeah
i gotta say when i was preparing this
segment i wasn't anticipating how long
it was gonna take yeah joey chestnut
there is a beautiful sport because that
is what that was like
so slow in my head like people watching
are like why is it taking them eight
minutes
maybe we could do like half if you hated
that please or just the wiener
oh no
just the glitz
these internet fans pay for so much uh
more hardcore stuff
if they do another 100 it's two so yeah
yeah
25 minutes um it's very hot it's very
hot you pull out just a chair
kick back eat a hot dog
make some content i thought this would
be a fun day uh in a recent interview
with the direct miss marvel actress
i didn't practice this before travana
springer it was an easy name trevina
thank you she's a friend of mine oh i
was thinking i was thinking about that
why is she not on the show
anyway
do you want to read the story sure it's
your friend yeah miss marvel actress
trivina springer uh opens up about
marvel's secrecy it's really interesting
because the day that i got my audition
material sagar who plays amir who's a
friend of mine sent me a text message
and it was like hey this character came
in i think you should audition for it
and i was like i am how do you know this
so the most interesting thing here is
that she didn't know who else was in the
cast until the day before so no
rehearsals or anything let me let me
clarify uh
because you read that cold uh she
she didn't know who was gonna be on the
she her friend had like reached out was
like hey i heard you're auditioning for
this role that's super exciting she
didn't know he had also gotten a part in
ms marvel until she got her call sheet
which if you're familiar with production
you get that the day before and she was
like oh [ __ ]
my friend's gonna be there tomorrow and
they're
i think they're playing they play
husband and wife in that he's in that
show
very funny that they had no talked about
him they had no like
i'm so sorry to glitch
but my toes are not that's a different
hot dog baby
different piggies different piggies if
we had 200 i'm going to do something
i've never done which is give this dog
human food and you'll get to see him
walk eat a glass on
camera he's so cute okay we've got a
couple more headlines before we uh talk
about stranger things miss marvel has
officially sort of become
uh the highest rated rotten tomatoes
show for disney plus which is amazing
it's it's sitting comfortably at a 96
rating right now
loki and juan vision i think and and
hawkeye were all sort of in that like 92
to 96 range i think the only
uh marvel studios or lucasfilm disney
plus anything that has a higher
uh
rating or whatever is clone wars season
seven which has a hundred percent on
rotten tomatoes um which surprises me
but i like the back of the season was
really strong can the audience sway the
vote or is it the 100 from the people
that ninety percent separate yeah that
96 is for critics so there's an audience
quoting critics scores so the critics
gave clone wars 100 people we all don't
know how many critics are gonna be like
seven yeah
but i'm curious because the the shows
and like this is all the love all the
shows i think the disney plush shows
have been overall a really great way to
get the comic book flavor because comics
are serialized so longer form tracks
better for comic books but what i found
interesting is we get through one
through four it has a certain flavor and
then episode five tends to be like
here's a lot of data and then episode
six is like how do we stop and so i find
that most the landings aren't stuck in
quite the way the show starts as so i'll
be curious one how this marvel lands but
two what those ratings look like once we
start to get that pattern like over the
benefit of time do people change how
they feel about these disney shows or
does disney plus start to adjust the
pacing because i think they could use
nine episodes some of the time sometimes
they could use four like it could flex
totally there is also like a weird sort
of industry thing that you might not
know about unless you're paying really
keen attention which is
you know reviewers only get a set number
of episodes before they get to write the
review for ms marvel uh that was the
first two episodes for midnight it was
the first four episodes so you know
disney does probably play a little bit
of a game where you know moon knight
episode four ended with that great sort
of reveal um
and you know they're probably very
intentional with that um but i would say
through the first four episodes of miss
marvel
96 in my book it's it's so good yeah
it's so good still holding on to moon
night unfortunately is that your
favorite
it was i think it's my favorite only
because it's not what i expected i was
like with a lot of people i'm sure was
just like oh yeah i don't really know
this much about this superhero that i
read the comic books and i was like oh
i'm obsessed and then the show i was
like oh oh that makes me so happy that's
perfect yeah it was great for me it's
loki i think loki was my like surprise
because i already loved loki and then
they did an existential crisis as a show
and they didn't go ship of theseus to
punching each other like i loved wanda
vision but the show totally shifted a
lot in the last episode whereas this
ended with this incredible shakespearean
performance from jonathan majors so to
me it stayed the most totally accurate
and was also the most thought provoking
for me but if miss marvel lands like it
could be number two it could be no it's
definitely number two once they were
also disney please release the script
for just the last episode of loki
i want to read that monologue so quietly
without jonathan oh my god it's so good
i like witches anyways uh wow
oh can we hit that spoilers mortis
chrissy of course we mentioned moon
knight has to uh get a comment in tell
us about his decoy chrissy says to koi
how do you think string theory has come
into play in the mcu chrissy with these
heady questions just not let me rest
that's right nexus events are vibrating
strings but shake too much and they
affect strings around them causing a
ripple and an absolute point that sounds
like a theory i actually have an answer
for this okay okay so i think they're
leaning into nexus beings nexus beings
are characters within the mcu that are
are definitive so the scarlet witch is
the nexus being it seems like they're
leaning towards doctor strange being at
least visually a nexus being i would
have had him encounter other doctors
strangers that didn't look like him
therefore there was like an implication
that there was a variable because i
don't think it's possible that's another
conversation but nexus beings are fixed
points in space and time i think the way
nexus beings are used in the mcu uh
versus in the marvel comics is that
they're kind of gravitational there's
something that is drawing in what's
going to be happening so say you could
like
soothe say say you could see through
space and time it would be a point where
you would use that as a benchmark you
could look for x y or z and know that
things were going to change before or
after that point so it's a fixed point
and i see that as kind of a
gravitational draw so i think it's
string theory up until that point of the
fixed point so there are divergent
timelines around that fixed point but i
think what we're going to find as we get
to secret wars as we get to the
evolution of kang as we evolve the tva
is that there are certain things that
are always solid and that everything
kind of warps reality around them if
that makes sense oh
i like loki's hair
does that make sense yeah okay
i i chucked the spoilers uh graphic up a
little early but i just wanted to say
this there's not really big spoilers for
thor love and thunder it's in the news
um
it's a spoiler for something that's not
going to be in the movie so if you're if
you're like really trying to avoid
things maybe uh hit mute and check back
in with us when the thing drops but uh
but for right now um
we have gotten some news about a couple
of people who have been cut out of the
film um
namely peter dinklage and jeff goldblum
were going to be in scenes obviously as
etre and the grand master
we assume
probably gore went on a killing spree
and killed some of these characters or
something like that uh i can't say i
haven't seen the film um and
additionally lena heady was going to be
in the film and she ended up not making
it in either we're not going to go into
any of this too much further because
again some of us have seen the movie
some of us have not um and i don't want
to spoil anyone so we can drop that
little spoiler thing and you guys can
come back
perfect also um thank you celina those
in the chat we are going to get to
stranger things shortly we just do like
a new show do our headlines first and
then get into the meteor bits right
after the headlines so we're just
bringing you the news first in general
what's happening today and yesterday and
then we'll get into the heavy stuff and
i was answering an existential question
for chrissy which was fun for me
i also think chrissy is right that there
is going to be different multiverses
fixed points but i do think there's
going to be ultimately fixed points like
iwatu would watch over but that's
another longer conversation cool we'll
do that oh the dog okay a couple more a
couple more headlines and we're getting
a stranger things like jessica said i'm
gonna go fast
deadpool 3 is coming along nicely but
the writers rhett reese and paul wernick
were on a podcast recently and they said
they were really excited to be bringing
deadpool into the mcu because they in
their words they're what like 28 or 29
movies that we can kind of play with so
it sounds like they're having a ton of
fun with this new universe that they can
pick apart and make jokes over and they
said no
mcu movie is safe from some insults
about
uh from from deadpool we've talked a lot
i think this is how you bring in the r
rating and i think this is a really
clever way to break the fourth wall in
universe and out of universe i think
this is how you set the precedent for
our rating i think this is also how you
set the precedent for there being
multiple universes in a non-multiversal
way yeah if deadpool knows he's in a
comic he could also know he's in a movie
if he knows he's in a universe you can
acknowledge the fox universe if we know
there's a fox universe you can have a
secret
he can't get across the table he's not
smart enough
oh my god pick him up no i'm joking
don't pick him up okay now we're getting
into our discussion that you guys are
asking about about stranger things
stranger things chapter four volume two
releases tonight technically tomorrow
midnight i'm that person don't be mad at
me
it's probably one you mean tomorrow
uh drops at midnight and we and also
remember the boys drops like 5 p.m today
and we couldn't be more excited this
season has been nuts so we wanted to
take some time to talk about it send us
your questions question number one what
have you loved most about the past
season i want to know from the chat and
i want to know from you guys here
and by past season this season this
season yeah this season the season that
we're in part one of stranger okay
oh stranger things yes because i brought
up the boys and i was like which one are
you talking about
also great also a great show very bleak
very bloody i do like how they end on
starlight every episode but cleveland's
about which are frustrating things i
will i can start my favorite thing so
this past season i was i'll be honest i
it took me a minute to get into it it
took me up until maybe like the
third episode because i was getting a
lot of and you
please don't do what i did um
i wasn't paying attention to winona
ryder's parts that i'm trying to save
hopper i was kind of like i don't need
this i just need to know what 11 is
doing i just need to know about 11 and
that is it and once we saw vechna and
actually killing individuals that's when
i got really into it so i think my
favorite part of this past season is
just vekna and introducing new
characters because i think you need to
keep doing that or else we just are
getting two we can grab on to the
characters that we've already seen but
remember this was supposed to be an
anthology series and i think that would
have been really successful so i think
bringing in new people make it feel like
that's like the best of both worlds
and your og's anthology and yog's yeah
you got your ogs you got your new
characters in fact that was my favorite
part well i do love how at the end of
stranger things episodes the season a
kid dies especially in the first few so
like that made it feel like a serialized
regular kind of network tv show which it
hadn't really ever felt like before like
it did feel serialized like we were
watching the same story play out but
like every episode of my dying also
heightened the stakes so like now that
nancy is possessed by becna and like uh
we're looking out for
redhead girl character max that's her
name um i do think that uh gives a nice
new slash old element to stranger things
um yeah and i do like how the characters
are all coming together slowly but
surely they were all separated so and so
was in california so so was it russia
you like that they're separated i do but
i like the how they're coming together
though like i like even though they're
worlds apart they're all brought
together by the power of love
i hated that they separated maybe that's
just me it made it so difficult
especially because like someone in the
chat said um
um will's brother
jonathan jonathan is going to die and i
was like i have no attachment to
jonathan he's been gone a
um i i think like the struggle that i've
had with stranger things in past seasons
was like they were introducing a lot of
new characters and i was like i care
about these guys i don't know if i care
about max i don't know if i care about
um
who's who's brett gelman's character the
the like oh
yeah yeah yeah some some of these
characters and i feel like this season
they've like really fleshed out a lot of
those new characters and made you care
for them a lot more um
but my favorite thing about this most
recent season i'm such a lore hound and
i was always like what's going on with
that upside down and getting to kind of
get more into the flashback stuff and
get more into like
what is happening is what i'm very
excited for and what i'm enjoying yeah
aaron weddle in the chat said number one
rule in dnd never break up the party i
think they're doing a good job of that
because when we left off they're in the
upside down together they are not
leaving they are not leaving as a unit
stay together if you split up we know
only bad things can happen and i i'm
enjoying that aspect to me it feels like
the x-men like in the x-men comics
you've got different teams but they all
have to come together to fight the big
bad and i feel like this whole season
we've kind of seen the different teams
and now we're getting that uniting but
they've also done a really good job of
playing with their expectations like i
really thought steve was gonna bite it
when he went through the upside down and
then they switched him with nancy
visually like there was a moment where
it's like oh now she's in trouble and we
very much knew that steve as a
babysitter is our favorite thing steve
working with uh little baby hawk is our
favorite thing so he's obviously the
most likable one to kill and that's
usually a hard movie's work they they
give you that one great scene you're
like extra hurt they keep giving us
great steve scenes so we keep expecting
him to bite it and then they keep
twisting that there's a billboard down
the street that says like save steve
netflix put up like there's literally
they know what we want and they know how
to manipulate us so my favorite thing
about this season is that it feels like
the first season was written by fans for
fans and then the second season felt
like they were trying to aliens alien
and didn't succeed and then the third
season they gave us some fun summer
hijinks now they feel like it's fans
written for fans of what season one was
like it's almost like a metamodernistic
take on what succeeded the first season
yeah yeah i this season also because we
all learned that this is the most
expensive show that netflix is running
you can tell oh my god that looks so
i always go to like smoking a cigarette
because i think that's such a funny
visual but yes just like like relaxing
between takes is always cracking me up
you guys in the chat are hashtagging
protect steve save jonathan
who do you think will die i see a lot of
you guys thinking it's gonna be not
steve which honestly i think i
ultimately do think it's nancy only
because for storytelling purposes she's
connected to literally everyone killer
killer the most impactful
but if it is jonathan or steve if it's
steve i would be okay i have a wild card
theory that just kind of occurred to me
tell me i think it might be will
they might get rid of i don't i was
thinking about putting will on the
thumbnail that would be so sad if they
kill will here's why like because that
exactly he's like
he doesn't do anything well that too so
then also like but he was the first one
to be no no no no yeah yeah so they
might kind of bring it back because i
might go after him after nancy and
will is kind of it feels like they're
trying to
uh
come bring him out of the closet yeah
and
they skipped pride month yeah
for parts one and two so they were like
we know we're gonna kill well we're
gonna get a drink
i'm not holding your hand i thought we
were on this side
[Applause]
i think they would kill uh will by him
turning into vecna because you see how
mad he is at like everyone right now
he's like the resentment flowing through
him is so hard and aggressive watch
becky take him again and be like yo dude
you can just team up with me we can just
be one and then he's gonna like
sacrifice himself
and becca is gonna die but he's going to
turn into whatever beckner was but he's
not going to kill kids he's just going
to stay in the upside down forever and
then poor winona ryder will come back
and be like where's one of my two sons
i think it's going to be the opposite
where i think because will was the one
in peril in season one it'll be joyce
in season four that either dies or looks
like she'll die so we're sort of like
hopper in season three i guess i hope
they don't do any more fake out deaths
um i think it'll be joyce and the kids
are like oh an adult is in trouble if
it's five who do we like i i see you're
[ __ ] you can somehow tell me where
you found that evidence because i read
it online but they don't believe me
people are dying the thing is watch them
say five people dying and it's going to
be like the russian guard
one of the flights
the bats
that's more than five that's where we
over performed
i i do think it's gonna be unfortunately
steve and honestly it's worse i think
it's a business standpoint i love it i
think homeboy's gotta have a career like
he's gonna go make movies well that's
why like i honestly like he was a free
guy he's great i think he's about to
like have his like i think it's that
okay get me off the show yeah like we
got steve we got will we got nancy i
think nancy's biting it too though oh i
think joyce
steve nancy joyce
correct me if i'm wrong it can't be it
can't be that group i'll say that right
it's like someone i feel like an adult
does have to die and watch it be the guy
with the glasses though it could be
breakdown yeah he's had a lot of moments
this season like the moments thing i was
talking about
you always have that big moment and then
you know they take out people you're
endeared to we're pretty endeared to him
right now oh okay lion of demise just
said unpopular opinion dustin gonna die
he is smartest has the most healthiest
relationship they uh and they've shown
him losing in dna
that's the only theory that's the only
character i'll get really upset about
which is what they want yeah it'll be
like uh it'll be my um steve steven yoon
and um
and the walking dead i do also have a
pick out you'll see something
oh god if they kill dustin i will while
out because also
his mom we and we we're thinking about
these parts but we forget that they also
ended with the parents being like we
gotta kill eddie everyone in the town is
like eddie's the reason these things are
happening and we love his parents his
parents we're gonna see if we see his
parents morning dustin it's gonna break
this i do think eddie eddie is an easy
character to kill him yeah he's gonna
die i think it's not crying
i think because they've killed off the
new character in the other seasons they
always kill off the newbie since barb
they've always killed off the new person
that's kind of the barb spot i think
because of that we get eddie
if we're skipping pride month then eddie
will probably die i assume
i kept saying eddie was gay this entire
time and i still stand up it's the
he's just an best rocker
it's okay
but oh okay so do you think 11 created
the upside oh this is a good question
do you guys especially you in the chat
do you guys think 11 created the upside
down because i think so
i think that's kind of what they applied
and i think a little bit further this is
so hard you know i think if she created
the upside down
she would be able to
not just seal it but destroy it yeah and
maybe that's where we're going
but we
i don't know i don't know i feel like
it's beyond her i think she opened it
i don't think she created it i think it
always existed oh you think it always
exists yeah that's what a lot of people
say and
i guess
when we uh whitney did the breakdown
there is evidence to like it's already
been existed before her but i still like
i think her power was like
she threw him there but she also did
create it with her powers but maybe
we're wrong maybe we'll get more into
that there's the like nature thing of
like equal and opposite you know like
when we create something there's the the
opposite creation so maybe it's always
existed once they started doing kind of
experiments and like therefore it was
birthed from these experiments and then
so it's also that she opened it she's
the portal that's why it is where it is
but maybe once they started messing with
the mental powers of things it like grew
from that and then vacuum now wields it
because he's the strongest so then also
when nancy and them were she was looking
for her guns in the bedroom her bedroom
in the upside down she's like it's been
frozen since 11 opened it or whatever
back in the beginning
so it did exist that's why i think it
existed and then it got frozen when she
opened it oh interesting i like that
idea wellington which erica will not die
you have much
i trust oh we will rise you have your my
trust on that what and people have been
asking this in the chat people are
asking what eddie's what song eddie will
play will we get another 80 classic yeah
we do have that shot of him playing
guitar on the bus or whatever
i love it it's every time i see a scene
of someone aggressively playing a guitar
i think of the thing in mad max yeah
yeah yeah
shooting fire
yeah running up that hill in the trailer
for season four part two
but i do think like you can't predict
what song is going to chart right like
this kate bush song was just is popular
because you know it went off on tick
tock do you think that they like
you know the duffer brothers saw how
popular that song was and we're like we
got to cram some classics i think the
big the big get about choosing these
songs is going to the writers and being
like what's one song you really like
from the 80s because i think you can't
choose the popular ones you have to
choose the actual deep cuts i i only
like like four kate bush songs i'm sorry
you guys and this wasn't one of them i
didn't really listen to it but my mom
was like
that song is coming back
listen to that so i feel like it's gonna
be like it has to be something
underrated it has to be like i could see
being like a judas priest b side like
something that eddie would listen to
yeah yeah yeah some like other judas
priest like not a single something that
like he would listen to authentically
yeah that makes more sense than i was
thinking tick tock and abba
seems a little out of place
i feel like
if erica joins i want them to sing some
tina turner song for her entrance um i
like that yeah tina turner
um
oh there he is he's desperate he's
desperate you guys let us know in the
chat what you think is going to be
happening at the
and those stranger things well this
isn't the end they have one more season
after yeah it is wild i've i felt for so
long this was the final season and it
wasn't until we were doing this show
where i was like oh no no we're going to
get another season we're getting
ahead in the future like they got to be
in college yeah those kids are grown
yeah whoever lives they're grown yeah
we've gotten so far electric eye by
judas priest metallica creeping death
these are uh
also a little dovetailing into some of
the classic rock stuff in thor love and
thunder we can drop that spoiler they
actually had kate bush uh originally had
a song in thunder yeah
which is so funny that like what what
are the chances in twenty got two emails
like this crazy movies and on tv the two
biggest properties of the summer in 2022
right
um we're going to continue talking about
stranger things here in a bit but first
we want to thank some of the people who
brought us that was the most like
way to start ad copy i think i've ever
done
but we do want to thank athletic greens
for sponsoring us this week on the break
room um we have been taking ag-1 from
athletic greens to help boost our
immunity and give us energy throughout
the day i know that i will be downing a
packet of ag-1 after all these hot dogs
with one delicious scoop of ag1 you're
absorbing 75 high quality vitamins
minerals and whole foods sourced
superfoods probiotics and adaptogens to
help you start your day right this
special blend of ingredients supports
your gut health your nervous system your
immune system your energy you recover
focus it helps you with aging
like i said we've been sort of drinking
it all week and
when you eat an entire plate of hot dogs
something's got to give
and ag-1 can help you sort of get your
health back on track right uh it is
lifestyle friendly whether you eat keto
paleo vegan dairy-free gluten-free it
supports better sleep quality and
recovery mental clarity and alert
alertness it's cheaper than getting all
of your different supplements from
different places yourself and you're
investing in an all-in-one nutritional
insurance and for every purchase
athletic greens is going to donate to
organizations helping to get nutritious
foods to kids in need including no kid
hungry here in the united states right
now it's time to reclaim your health and
arm your
immune system with convenient daily
nutrition just one scoop in a cup of
water every day that is it no need for a
million different pills and supplements
to look out for your health and to make
it easy athletic greens is going to give
you a free year of
immune supporting vitamin d and five
free travel packs with your first
purchase all you have to do is go to
athleticgreens.com
break room again that's
athleticgreens.com
break room to take ownership over your
health and pick up the ultimate daily
nutritional insurance
um
in other news
jessica clemens is getting on a flight
tomorrow morning to go to austin
to be a part of the rtx austin 2022
podcast festival that is happening from
tomorrow through sunday so if you've
ever wanted to see some of your favorite
new rockstars host in person now is your
chance can i add something to you yes
it's sold out
oh this coffee is a little sold out for
some
day passes um but i think they still
have the three day passes and let me
tell you it's still a festival it's
still fun yeah there's uh on friday our
friend iffy is doing santa claus oh
that's so fun
yeah uh 90's doing comedy um the fiona
nova is going to be signing on friday
morning
i believe there's also a free
something i was looking at the schedule
i have no idea maybe maybe you have to
get tickets for it but it was free that
might be something look into the
schedule i just know that i'm sorry but
the single days uh have sold out if i
ask you if he knocks you he'll bench you
there you go
or
go ahead and click that link in the
description to see if there are some of
those three day passes still available
and when you do that use code new
rockstars all one word and that will
save you a little bit of money um and
regardless of whether or not um
the tickets are sold out we will be in
the area so if you live in austin and
and like just said it is a festival so
come by and maybe you'll run into one of
us there um and we hope those of you
have tickets we'll see you there
end of segments
smooth in smooth out handle down
we're about 25 away from
glizzy round two
and i will say the dog is here on the
carpet looking for food if uh
if someone's accidentally dropped a
piece of a bun it's okay if uh
if we do get that 200 level the dog will
also participate um i will deal with the
consequences of that later
but it is now time for mandatory fun
play my graphic
it is actually mine because i mean
um
play it again
i feel a sense of obligation
here on the break room
we're still talking about stranger
things
um
and
as most of you know stranger things has
this habit of taking fictional dungeons
and dragons monsters and turning them
into sort of living
monsters and nightmares we had
uh the demogorgon from season one we had
mind flayer in season two and three
we've got vecna now in season four and
hopefully beyond that's my favorite
character from the new season
but i thought it would be fun we have a
monster manual here
i thought it'd be fun if i just paged
through the monster manual and got some
classic d d monsters and we could maybe
figure out
how to integrate them into either season
four part two or season five um and i
don't know this is sort of a
free-for-all segment let's let's do it
also a reminder in the chat we are like
so close to breaking another hundred
where we have to
see who can eat two hot dogs the
quickest it's not just
gonna take a while i know you want us i
don't want to do it
was the ketchup and mustard helpful i
mean it seems like not because you guys
lost yeah
spicy it did slightly lubricate the bun
the bun was so dry like it was it was
cartoonish
these are fresh buns too we just got
them
i'm joking it's okay uh coy and i were
talking about eating earlier uh
yesterday if you watch that show um
let's start with this
let's start with this on the cover of
this uh copy of the monster manual a
beholder
a classic dungeons and dragons monster
it has all these eye stocks that shoot
out crazy beams that do a bunch of
different stuff
i want to see a beholder in stranger
things um do we think this is
how how can we get a beholder in
intriguing season five
uh the upside down breaks through and
the first thing that sees in order to
communicate with the upside down to our
world is a beholder because it witnesses
our world and communicates back you
think it's like it's been watching the
whole time it's got like a control room
doesn't this look like mike wazowski
with a bunch of people
like mike wazowski broke back
it's mark wazowski
yeah um what do each of the eyestalks do
do you think oh we're getting closer uh
that first one all the way to the left
shoots silly strings okay silly strings
but it burns a little bit
uh the neck the one all the way on the
right side that one silly putty
lots of silly i'm gonna go x-ray for the
one above the silly putty uh and then
i'm gonna go like heat vision for the
one above that right now all i'm getting
is like really good party clown
i mean you're not wrong what if he's a
friend of the gang oh what if we finally
have a monster you know what i actually
think that'd be very funny we haven't
had like a slimer yep and that's strange
we did get a little bit of that in
season two with uh dustin and his little
little
guy
off-screen producer dodson was pitching
a bug bear or an owl bear um being in
season five of stranger things and i
thought it would be fun to have a little
someone using a bug bear uh an alberta
as they're familiar
um
yeah we also had the the russian scene
in this scene where like the it did
effectively help them the demogorgon
like overall benefited them so maybe
it's that time we just full on pokemon
catch them all i love
like long form effect helped him like
they're now out of that prison
yeah
i'm just saying that you got to get
creative
that's a stretch i mean
they really
[Applause]
okay after this i will go grab a camera
and give them a hot dog okay okay so we
have two each okay which one of these
one of these is gonna be spicy i just
know it yeah i can't see any difference
or they're old
okay
[Laughter]
you guys in the chat go ahead and tell
me who you think is going to win this
hot dog eating contest we have john
let's do a poll uh coy
eric and john i was trying to think of
hot dogs i'm gonna bet john you're in
bed john because he he hit him
he was far enough ahead of us
you got you were starting we were
catching up the trick for well i won't
tell my tricks yeah until after yeah
yeah yeah i'm going to try 300. you have
to release the throat that's what john
was going to say
i'm going to try a totally different
tactic this time thanos because they
said brian sandler and i agree thanos
cassanus
ready
set
go oh he's dipping in the water he's
dipping in the water oh my god it's
getting all over the controller oh my
god he's dipped in the water and it's
working the technique is working oh oh
the technique is working oh and the dog
is in the dog wants to get some of that
dog
john is doing the water technique and
though it is disgusting he is succeeding
oh we're almost there we're almost there
corey let me see how much you a lot coy
boy you got a lot
too much water too much water throws up
just roy said don't close your eyes i
don't know the chatter if that's to you
guys makes you eat quicker um spicy
that was the spicy one
um oh my god uh jennifer bruno said eu
um a hot dog then water y'all gonna make
me act up said wandy we got two hot dogs
down already
you only one and a half you only ate one
welcome the true mind player is that
your first one i know way better okay
john costa
oh no everybody poor thing
i'm not gonna look
keep it on too keep it on too but keep
that mic hot
pick it up a notch i'm gonna enjoy the
second one now because that was that was
a dubious man i don't know how we just
give me uh camera four real fast
someone's gonna vibe with this hot dog i
hope you guys support the july is just
like this how much glizzy
over there
no no look over here eric you're going
to get them here give him the hot dog oh
okay
come here
is this is this good good thing you're
right
oh
okay play better to camera hank
hank your butt is to the camera but he's
so handsome though oh
all of them look at them every side
thank you there we go good job you guys
but again you lost to john costa i feel
disgusted someone said i cheated i lost
how did i change
this is the first time i've ever
taken a tums type thing how many do you
do what do you do i do two
does anyone have never taken tubs no oh
i always delightful feel strong it's not
candy
the water did it help it's a cheat code
yeah it melts the bun i want to see
i want to see a hot dog eating contest
from the professionals where they're not
allowed to use water oh cause that was
like it's dry it's super dry
it's insane how hard it is to eat a
hotdog fast without water like it you
don't realize how much it just attacks
yeah yeah it's tough okay you know
whistle challenge pretzel with the
saltines it's that but like speedy
yeah it was such a bad idea being like
if we reached 300 they'll each do three
hot dogs i was afraid
to be at like six by now i was afraid
that what eric has already had yeah
before he would wait oh yeah
yeah well now not down one but yeah
understandably okay
um
you guys that was fun uh i think we have
a bunch of people who are sent in super
chats we have a few more minutes do we
want to go through those yeah let's do
that let's do super chats also the the
the poll said you were going to win 42
percent correct 35 koi was completely
last apparently i was cheating on my
diet which is that's true that is real
that is cheating that's real and i'm
it's like popcorn it takes forever to
eat it's like a slow process you can
season it
we were talking before the show about
sort of marvel's protocols when you go
to one of the premieres of their films i
would love it if you brought in
artichokes they're like we actually
don't have a policy for this we don't
have anything on the books but you're
not welcome back
i wanted to be known right now if i see
you here
i'm calling the police on
christmas like no i get it
okay a couple people were excited about
the glizzy contest we've got brian
sandler saying thanos because the anus
just read that earlier
300 i will throw a hot dog directly in
john's mouth for you oh
i can do it
it was mostly gulp gulp gulp if i'm
being totally honest
um
i like this from rance almor who says
tarask please talking about a dungeons
and dragons monster that's the one
that's like sort of dinosaur looking but
also the size of like the united states
basically um so that was you know i do
think the upside down could basically be
like
or stranger things could basically say
like yeah the upside down's everywhere
now um and do that for season five might
be interesting surviving the upside down
when it's either surviving it or trying
to like seal it
have we seen like
russia's upside down or we've only seen
hawkins
i don't know
we've only seen
sorry someone has how many hours till
volume two it's eight hours oh yeah
eight hours and five minutes or if they
want to go to disney and say
eleven feet a little bit or beyonce and
just drop out of nowhere yeah just
dropping 10.
um weiss gold ttv says speaking of rtx
do you guys watch ruby
i have not watched ruby if you guys
aren't familiar that's uh an animated
show that rooster teeth produces um it's
been on for forever but i i watched red
verse blue yeah i i have not watched
that throwback throwback well that's
what they do i think ruby is has been on
for quite some time too hey honey i'm
not giving you food you think you can
win and i'm not gonna
[Music]
elijah bowser says we need more of
susie's family that was entertaining
yeah
um and and i also like getting dizzy he
says not ready to see dustin crying over
steve dying that is the relationship
that i care the most about chelsea
i didn't do it it was eric what
the most on camera you can be there's
multiple cameras
oh
um that is the relationship that i care
the most about on this entire show i
will say um
why do you all look like the stranger
things cast members
i don't
know
i don't like it
i don't know you could be uh eddie why
don't you be uh billy i'm like
wow
i think it's weird because i'm like
you're kind of destiny with the funness
so maybe dustin i'll tell you chat let
me know if i
mean how insulted i should be
sean bell says michael is going to save
nancy i i think nancy's gone i think
she's toast you guys think nancy's gonna
eat it dude nancy's definitely gonna die
and if she doesn't die i will give
everybody in the chat ten dollars
speaking of people who
want careers right hasn't hasn't
natalie dryer sort of had the
most success outside of maybe millie
bobby brown from this show oh absolutely
i've only seen uh nancy in one other
film and oh it was so the horny catholic
yes yes yes god yes loved it yeah yeah
yeah but if you haven't seen it
and you were raised religious it is uh
uh
see this is what's happening
to mess with that character you love
your headphones i saw it i saw billy
i'll take some billy max combo i
appreciate that uh uh our good friend
mezzo jd says steve's last loving words
are always the babysitter and sacrifices
himself dustin screams screen goes black
for a few seconds and then comes back
and we do that's so sad
i mean he did have his fake out when he
fell into the upside down and things
were eating him at the end of that
sudden he got right i was like oh he's
gonna die
do you think that we're gonna get just
like death death death death death or do
you think like a group of people sort of
like um
this is a weird comp but you know that
like it in harry potter seven part two
where it was just like oh yeah 15
characters died in the span of like five
minutes do you think we're going to get
that kind of a situation where a bunch
of characters are all sort of dying
to three and a two
what if like when the parents are like
running after trying to find eddie becna
just goes on a killing spree from the
adults
just starts murdering and then they
start realizing as one individually they
go into the air and break their law
their legs and necks that's when they're
like oh this isn't eddie
it's like been right in front of them
you know how mad i would be to be an
angry an angry mob and then realize oh
we're chasing the wrong thing
do you think it would be interesting to
see that get that like trope of a bunch
of like people with pitchforks like
chasing down eddie and then eddie gets
killed by the thing that they think he
is you know
in front of them yeah right
that gets eddie
if he dies in a different way i don't
mind but but if he actually succeeds
when he gets them i will be upset
that'll be a sad one i will be okay
on that one let's see we've got a couple
more minutes i want to get through some
of these other super chats rachel grande
says happy fourth happy fourth to
everyone out there that celebrates uh
poke drew said damn disney copyright
strike do you your doctor strange video
does this happen a lot i should read
that before i said it out loud
we were putting out we were putting out
a doctor strange re-breakdown today on
the youtube channel it might be back up
sometimes it happens um sometimes it
doesn't youtube has sort of their auto
filter and sometimes we get caught up in
that and then we just have to have a
conversation with them and and usually
they're pretty cool about hello doctor
strange yes yes
it wasn't a blanket
do you want a glizzy doctor
we have dozens um
fray girl another another great
moderator for us has a question my
question for you all if you could be a
hero or a villain in an already
established universe who would you be
and why
uh i want to be harley quinn okay
easy i would love to be able to be a
super gymnastic person but also this dog
don't quit because you did it
go to camera 4 go to camera 4.
this dog don't quit camera 4.
look at them
um i think i would choose lex luthor
because
a lot of money and uh and then
i have a kinder sensibility i want to
hopefully use that money for good oh
yeah is that a cheat money is recession
for example that's very true yeah who
are you choosing spider-man oh that's
not gonna be any
superhero i'd be spider-man yeah you got
the dc shirt on
don't look at me okay
you know i'm going to go legion i think
i'd want to be able to compartmentalize
mike oh uh
clearly not no but the idea of
compartmentalizing my powers in a
different mindset and having like a
journey through my own experience
through different world views and then
each of those having a different power
so if i could wield david holler's power
basically being able to be omnipresent
omni-aware and also all-powerful but
with some more control would be dope
cool cool sick sick sick nasty um we
need to go because uh we have a lot to
watch tonight this is johnny this is
john's way being like my stomach is
upset
throw up we need to watch an episode of
the boys tonight and some of us are
trying to watch five hours of strength
four hours of strangers tonight 5 p.m we
hope if amazon gives us the content that
we want yeah me and marina will be on
the boys underground tomorrow morning
and we're gonna start shooting at eight
before i get on my flight at like nine
so you know i'm going to rush also you
know what i love you guys in the chat so
much
keep going off about umbrella academy
maybe jessica will do it
maybe jessica will do it okay this is
the secret that you guys don't know
about new rockstars i'm gonna get fired
don't do it don't do it if you tweet it
eric
there's a higher likelihood we'll talk
about it only when i started
he's going to get 15 tweets right now
and yeah like someone said something
space your tweets out schedule your
tweets
tomorrow do something next and just just
work days with him he's going to be very
upset
there's footage of this just like she
didn't put that hot dog speaking of
three days with eric you can spend three
days with eric if you have tickets to
rtx and and because of that we will not
have a show tomorrow we'll also not have
a show on monday because it's the fourth
of july weekend and we're taking some
time off so um we will see you on
tuesday it's thor love and thunder week
next week also we'll probably be back
talking about stranger things but until
then have a great weekend everybody
thank you for coming happy bye time bye
guys